can a normal camera produce footage like
this or are the images of this Lake in
town being captured by a drone this
video takes us on a trip around
beautiful Hajj docked in Upper Austria
hashtagged is full of surprises
British photographer Jeff Tomkinson
lives in Austria in the summer he tried
out his hyper zoom
time-lapse technique in Ashdod
I presume is a new technique that I've
developed which enables me to zoom
extreme distances like I could I could
zoom across the whole Lake to a leaf on
the other side but then it's one step
beyond that because that in itself is is
pretty cool but what I wanted to be able
to do and what I've achieved is to be
able to actually be at the end of the
zoom when I'm there so I can zoom across
to the leaf and then when i zoom back
out from the leaf I'm actually at that
location so it's as if the camera has
traveled it's like a zoom travel travel
by zoo
Tomkinson spent two days filming in Hajj
dad he had decided on the exact camera
positions in advance I think there's
about 14 to 15 different static
positions that the camera was set up to
do the shots and that enables us then to
link them together and make it look like
the cameras flying although there is
nothing actually flying it so it's a
virtual camera really it's the camera
motion is all done in three-dimensional
space in the computer Tomkinson began
working as a photographer in the 1980s
his images have appeared in a number of
renowned publications including Life ko
and National Geographic he's been
working on time-lapse videos for 15
years ever the experimenter his focus
has always been on developing new tips
and tricks
I presume is his latest invention before
he made the hajj video
he used the technique to film in Venice
everything you're seeing behind me here
now is hyperlapse so the camera can move
huge distances it can spin buildings
around it can move through crowds and
it's very non disruptive because there
are no rails on the floor it's a matter
of moving the Rigby a tripod or on
wheels or whatever from one position to
the next so next to the next taking
shots at regular intervals in each new
location hyper zoom is a system based on
extreme zoom ranges and sliding from one
position to the next with a kind of a
virtual camera so that it looks like the
cameras flying he doesn't want to give
away all the secrets of his I presume
technique but he does reveal how he
managed to produce the footage from
within the boat I have to shoot a hyper
lapse type sequence with the camera
actually traveling through the boat so
I'm using this stabilized gimbal rig
which keeps things very stable so if I
move it that it doesn't move hyper zoom
technology requires extensive
post-production thousands of pictures
together create the illusion of movement
you took an entire month of editing to
create the 90 second video in all
photography every phase is important and
you have to do your absolute best to be
perfect in each phase so you plan it's
the best way you can then you shoot it
the absolute best way you can and then
you post produce it the absolute best
Baker and there's no one part of those
that you can ignore and expect to get
good results out of the end and who
knows with any luck Jeff Tompkins ins
video of hodge dot could one day be
headed for Hollywood
you